actually i think i think we have a good
story for this topic and and what ian's
talking about let me pull this up this
is from sf gate walgreens is closing
five san francisco stores due to
organized retail crime
they say they give the addresses i'm not
going to read the addresses but they're
going to close
close five more stores a company
spokesperson confirmed tuesday said an
ongoing organized retail crime is the
reason
organized retail crime continues to be a
challenge facing retailers across san
francisco and we are not immune to that
retail theft across our san francisco
stores has continued to increase in the
past few months to five times our chain
average during this time to help combat
the issue we increased our investments
in security measures in stores across
the city to 46 times our chain average
in an effort to provide a safe
environment
we also heard target i believe it was is
going to change their hours because they
can't handle all of the theft
there's an interesting conundrum here
you've got in new york city right aoc
they want to do away with cash bail
i actually agree uh i i do i think that
if someone is accused of a crime
non-violent of course
and they're poor holding them and
demanding cash for them to leave is
is punishing someone who can't afford it
so we we have we're innocent until
proven guilty you can't hold me in lock
up before you've proven anything i'm
innocent
and so there's a really serious problem
then they started releasing repeat
offenders who were laughing as they were
committing these crimes you then take a
look at what's going on in san francisco
yeah they're overly lacks with what's
happening and now you're getting
businesses pulling out
so what's the answer more cops to arrest
people stop stop and frisk
or the government backs off
personal responsibility
how do you solve a problem like this
stop disarming people stop taking away
their ability to defend themselves you
fight back in new york city against
someone who is a clear aggressor and
attacker you will be going to jail
that's an absolutely absurd law that
creates more victims creates less
personal responsibility and creates a
situation where criminals thrive
criminals literally have the the carte
blanche many times in new york city to
do whatever they want because there's
many instances of police officers
standing back watching crimes happen
watching people get hurt and they're
saying well i'm having an argument with
the government so i'm just not going to
do anything uh you know they'll arrest
you in two seconds if you've got a gun
though they'll arrest you in two seconds
if you have a political sign in the
wrong place and you're saying the wrong
message uh as well so there's been many
instances of businesses that got shut
down by by you know police officers by
sheriffs
all throughout new york city because
they just wanted to have their business
open meanwhile
black lives matter protest even on fox
news cops standing around the corner
with their arms uh you know hugging
themselves as businesses are being
eluded and the cops are just standing
there so you think like the the store
owners should be armed and fire no i
believe in personal responsibility and
if you're going to be incentivizing
people to get away with crimes you
should incentivize people to defend
themselves and to be able to not be
victims of those crimes i guess the
theft is a non-violent crime so it's
tough to authorize like a storm
if someone's stealing something right in
front of you right out of your hands i
mean there's an argument that's to be
made but out of your store like if
you're a store owner and they were
robbing your shelves it's not really
ethical to fire your weapon at them um
so
i struggle with this idea that i have to
restrict myself to the amount of force
that's being used i mean i'm not
necessarily sure if someone comes into
my store and starts taking my things out
that it you know i have to say restrict
myself to
in in the amount of force i use to put a
stop to that
for example
i don't think it would be fair to say
well
you're a lot bigger than that guy is so
you'll have to find someone smaller to
tackle that thief
i don't i don't think that that that's a
good ethical principle now that said
i also don't think that
because because what you're saying this
this is how that's going to turn out
someone's going to be like stealing a
package of lip gloss and some guy's
going to open fire with a shotgun
part of what happens is i i think that's
acceptable
um and i'll just say sorry to interrupt
but uh if someone is committing a crime
in your store
this is one of the things you learn
right away when it comes to home defense
people you know you had dave chappelle
who was like he did that stand-up bit
where he's like you know birdshot
birdshot buckshot birdshot buckshot and
everyone i talked to says absolutely not
buckshot buckshot buckshot buckshot
buckshot because you don't know that
person breaking into your house if you
point a weapon at them they could end
you and if someone is in your store
committing a crime and you think it's
just lip gloss i'll be nice to them and
they pull out a revolver or whatever
there's that uh that that video went
viral of the cop just just recently he's
outside taking the guy out of the car
and the dude pulls out a rifle and just
starts shooting at him yeah so so the
difficulty is i i think the point you're
making is
restricting someone's use of force
i i certainly think that if somebody is
committing a crime you should be able to
use force to stop them to protect
yourself because you don't know to what
extent
right i mean crime is rising it's very
tough it's there's no universal answer
but i think it's clear that crime is
rising where crime is allowed where
prosecutors aren't going after people
where police officers are looking the
other way and i think there's also other
societies that are polite societies that
they know a lot of people are armed a
lot of people are willing to defend
themselves and there's an effect knowing
that hey uh there's a responsibility
here that is known by everyone that if
you do cross a certain line there are
ramifications that you will have to pay
for those specific lines and i think the
more people are able to assert
themselves the less aggressors they
would have against them and things there
would be less harm there would be less
violence there would be less crime there
would be less people hurt overall
in the long run uh than if in the
current system that we have right now i
don't mean to derail you though so no
the point i'm getting though is is a big
one about institutional trust
if you don't trust the cops to enforce
the laws if you think that the cops are
actually going to make things worse
which is a number of what people from i
don't know black lives matter might
argue that the cops make things worse
when that when that institutional trust
in the prosecutorial system in the jail
system in the
police system degrades into roads and
people start removing that away and the
ability for cops to
[Music]
enforce the law goes the incentive
structure is such that someone's going
to say look i'm gonna run into this
store
i can just go with my duffel bag and go
through the jewelry section and just you
know five to ten of us will just go in
and then walk out and if you're not
going to prosecute crimes say under a
thousand dollars or under 500 because
it's not worth it it incentivizes those
crimes because the guy's gonna say well
what are you gonna do about it there's
five of us
so
so what needs to happen is
you you have to be able to bring about a
situation
where the police are able to enforce the
law without abusing the authority given
them to enforce the law and that's the
difficult point because on the one hand
there's an awful lot of people and i
think that i mean i think i would get
some sympathy for me and with this to
say man have you seen how some cops
behave when they're enforcing the law
the way that they they treat citizens um
the way people are treated in prisons i
mean it's absolutely abhorrent
but if you say well because of that
we're going to take away the cops power
to be able to arrest people and we're
going to try and and reduce
um
uh
people's engagement with law enforcement
under those circumstances by taking away
police power all of a sudden
there's now no incentive for somebody
not to rob a store and so i see this as
in large part as a function of the
destruction of the
trust in the institutions that are
enforcing justice so now what's
happening is that
uh on the one hand the the police were
viewed to have gone too far and in
places like san francisco seattle's
another one that has a huge problem
people said no we don't want the police
doing that we don't want the police
defund the police defund the police
defend the police defend the police pull
the police back we are now seeing the
fruit of those seeds beginning to bloom
in the disorder and the chaos
so it's i thought it was an interesting
question then on the on the on
levels of acceptable authoritarianism
right as it were police are allowed to
stop you detain you ask you questions
and they make an arrest based on you
know if they believe you've committed a
crime
and sometimes they're wrong and then as
people get locked up so there's a big
challenge you know ben franklin said it
is better that 100 guilty persons
escaped than one innocent person suffer
taking from blackstone's formulation of
10 guilty persons
so at what where do we draw the line
well as you mentioned when we say you
know what the cops are going too far
okay now your stores are closing down
because they're losing money right all
right well then bring the cops back in
okay now you're getting reports of cops
you know injuring people and arresting
old women like would be franklin say
it's it's better that 10 000 guilty
people go than one innocent suffer like
where's his threshold because he only
said 100. i'd say 10 000. 10 000. you
know why
if people can't have confidence that in
their innocence
they will be presumed to be innocent and
will will have a hope that they will not
be falsely accused or imprisoned then
the system has no uh no they'll have no
confidence in the system problem with
that is 10 000 people going to walgreens
and rob 500 bucks each and knock the
business out completely destroy the
business legally well not legally but
unprosecutorially
so maybe
man
challenges man morality is not black and
white you know it's like it's like it's
like i was saying uh i talked about this
with gender segregation and we'll
probably get into this in the members
segment where we get into this very
serious story about loudoun county which
is very very gross but um the same
arguments made today about gender
segregation were made about race
segregation back in the day
we have men and women have different
rooms while they're biologically
different and they should have their own
spaces they want to stay safe and a lot
of it's a lot of similar arguments a lot
of people reject it saying oh come on
the difference between race is marginal
and biology is you know between men and
women is very i'm not saying one thing
or another about any biology i'm saying
quite literally the arguments people you
say back in the day that they have right
segregation because they're different
now we have gender segregation men and
women have different rooms because
they're different so the same arguments
don't fly for the same issues right
there's just there's different
different than uh well they're raised
for sure there's just different things
we have different opinions about
different aspects of our existence so
it's not an easy black and white answer
there's no easy answer to a lot of these
questions there's always going to be
some kind of inequality there's always
going to be some kind of injustice but
in my own personal opinion when you get
rid of the state you get rid of a lot of
harm that could potentially happen if
you want to reduce harm you get rid of
the state
and you leave people on personal
responsibility for for you it is it's
never going to be easy but at the end of
the day i would argue that less people
would be hurt out of that system than
they are right now i don't think so
because if you remove the state
walgreens will hire a militarized army
to go over to
you know radio shack and blow everybody
down take an example
you're ian you're absolutely wrong
radio shack went out of business oh yeah
what's a walmart competitor uh radio
check can i ask a question walgreens and
walmart can i ask a question of course
okay so we're gonna get rid of the state
what's to stop me from having saying
well i'm gonna raise my own militia i'm
gonna take over a series of land and i'm
gonna own slaves i've now just created
my own mini state
the the things that power abortion is it
all comes back it's reciprocal
so my my point is i don't think saying
well just getting rid of the state
solves anything i mean so i'm canadian
we don't have life liberty in the
pursuit of happiness we have peace order
and good government i think that good
and effective government is necessary as
we've seen by the shoplifting thing i
don't think anyone benefits from saying
well we're all going to have our own
personal security guards at our own
stores to combat theft um
that's that's just not and i i'm going
to upset the libertarians in the crowd
but
uh i also don't think that things like
city planning can be done these in a
decentralized way and in a way that's
necessarily effective so
planning roads planning sewage um
planning electrical grids a lot of this
has to be centrally planned it's very
difficult to do if not impossible to do
in another way so
i don't think that's a solution but i do
think that
once you have a state that is not
exercising its power judiciously and
fairly and properly and competently once
you live in what we're in in a hyper
real fake
simulation or simulacra as it has to put
it um once you get into that kind of a
situation you end up with a with a
scenario where the trust in institutions
is broken and so those very institutions
that we that we institute that we create
in order to take care of a very very
important matters are not trusted and
people pull back from them they they're
going to start stepping outside the the
norms that those institutions upheld and
those things held together so what you
end up is you end up with a breakdown of
not just the
uh trust of the institutions but that
leads up to a cracking of the
organizational structure as well what
was that movie with natalie porton
portman annihilation
yeah have you guys seen that one yeah so
i'm a spoiler alert it's not that old of
a movie but it's been out for a long
enough time there's this weird alien
bubble when you go in dna is all mixed
and like animals have like plants
growing out of and creepy stuff's
happening and then in the end she
encounters an alien that looks just like
her and like that that's that's how i
imagine like simulacrum it's not a copy
it's a it's a cheap imitation of yeah
you know so you're saying when the state
gets too grotesque we need to we're not
maybe not need to but we would be good
to break it down into a into a
era of no state for a moment as we
reform a new state which is inevitable
well i think the jordan peterson
solution is you have to burn off dead
wood haven't you seen the meme of a v
for vent the v from v for vendetta and
he's got a headphone with a microphone
on it and he says your government is
doing what have you tried turning it off
and back on again
maybe that's you know thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you